bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 de votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité locale pour débuter
cette semaine loisirs le centre
aquatique du lac fête ses dix ans le 21
décembre 2002 il ouvrait ses portes au
public sur la ville de montigny le
bretonneux avec le soutien de la ville
de voisins-le-bretonneux je reçois donc
sur le plateau pierre paillasse et
alexandra rosetti bonsoir à tous les
deux vous êtes tous les deux élus à
montigny et à voisins le bretonneux nous
parlerons des festivités qui sont prévus
aussi du fonctionnement de ce complexe
qui accueille plus de 300 mille
personnes par an pour le moment voici
les titres du séduite de ce 18 février
le centre aquatique du lac situé à
montigny à 10 ans je vous le disais nous
en parlons avec nos invités nous nous
pencherons aussi sur les installations
techniques de ce site nous irons en
coulisses une nouvelle crèche
interentreprises vient d'ouvrir à
montigny le bretonneux également son nom
mon tipi elle peut accueillir une
trentaine d'enfants elle est réservée
aux parents salariés d'entreprises du
quartier d'activités du pas du lac
tanguy de lamotte le skipper versailles
a finalement bouclé son vendée globe
sont au tour du monde à la voile et en
solitaire il est arrivé dimanche aux
sables d'olonne après plus de 98 jours
de course il a pris l'avant dernière
place est toujours en sport le deuxième
bike and run de la minière cette
aiguille en cours les preuves d'une
distance totale de 12 km a rassemblé 300
participants parmi eux à frédéric
belaubre le triathlète professionnels
licenciés 2 e à saint quentin et pour le
point complet sur le sport le 7-8 sport
aux alentours de 18h30 si vous nous
suivez en direct avec anthony rech
mansois anthony bon sens wilfried un
cette fuite sport très riche 1 ce soir
je recevrai le président du comité
départemental de handball pas tricher ap
deux jours avant le quart de finale de
coupe de la ligue féminine qui se
déroulera à prési à plaisir mercredi
soir nous serons également en direct du
maroc avec l'équipage saint quentinois
qui participent au raid humanitaire le
4l trophy et puis comme d'habitude en
fin d'émission
tous les résultats du week-end et puis
on le disait tout à l'heure ses
week-ends vous étiez aux sables d'olonne
oui j'étais aux sables d'olonne
exactement pour l'arrivée de tanguy de
lamotte le skipper versaillais que nous
avons suivis pendant ces trois mois de
course 98
exactement vous aurez toutes les images
exclusives ses premières réactions au
bord du ponton tout à l'heure dans
l'émission sport et pour vous faire
patienter un petit peu sa toute première
réaction à votre micro ct ce week end on
regarde ce court extrait avant de
poursuivre cette édition je n'ai aucune
idée du nombre de personnes qui avaient
c'est pas ça qui est important c'est que
j'ai on arrive à g arrive un dimanche il
fait beau et je crois que les gens
avaient envie de mettre dehors pour voir
un skippeur du vendée globe qui
finissait sa course
donc voilà j'étais vraiment super je
suis vraiment super content et je mais
j'étais vraiment par contre étonné de
voir un avion avec une banderole de vaud
de voir autant de bateaux sur l'eau ça
samassa ça m'a marqué quoi c'est la
première course que je termine avec
autant de monde pour me suivre à une
heure de l'arrivée autant de monde tout
court c'était vraiment il y avait
vraiment du monde sur l'eau et ça ça ça
c'est vraiment important quoi ils peur
versailles et qui a donc bouclé son
vendée globe le reportage complet à
découvrir d'ici une vingtaine de minutes
sur notre antenne dans ce set 8 ainsi
que tous les résultats sport du week end
cette information concernant
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui disposent dorénavant du
premier restaurant universitaire
écologique de france les 10 tonnes de
déchets alimentaires et les huit tonnes
de déchets verts produits chaque année
elle sut par les cent trente sept mille
repas servis sur le site des sciences à
versailles servent maintenant d'engrais
naturel pour les espaces verts la ville
de versailles fondaterra l'université
son partenaire sur cette opération
débutée il ya trois ans sous le nom
assiette verte une nouvelle étape après
à la mise en place du tri sélectif un
bilan sera fait dans un nom de ce projet
pilote qui répond aux obligations du
grenelle de l'environnement et nous en
reparlerons bien évidemment demain au
cours de notre prochaine édition du 7 8
pour le moment loisirs et ce centre
aquatique du lac à montigny qui fête ses
10 ans
car paillasse maire adjoint à montigny
le bretonneux alexandra rosetti maire
adjointe au 6 mai à voisins le
bretonneux pour débuter cette séquence
on va découvrir ensemble notre chiffre
du jour le chiffre de cette édition 10
10 comme l'âge de ce centre aquatique
dont nous allons parler mais aussi comme
10 millions c'est le prix de ce complexe
inauguré le 21 décembre 2002 dès le
début c'était véritablement un projet
d'envergure investir 10 millions sur un
tel complexe
oui pour vouliez véritablement faire
quelque chose qui se démarque du reste
qu'elle était un petit peu le l'ambition
qui prévalait à l'époque c'est à dire en
ce qui concerne montigny le bretonneux
notre piscine tournesol avait fait son
temps avait vieilli et était devenu de
toute façon trop beaucoup trop petit
donc l'ambition c'était de faire un
projet assez important pour accueillir
l'ensemble des scolaires et le public
des dizaines de l'ensemble des résidents
que voisins le bretonneux s'est
manifestée en même temps pour faire
partie de ce projet voici les images
pendant vous parlez vous me racontez
comment ça s'est déroulé à cette époque
sont des images du chantier un des
images que nous avons sorti de nos
archives ya une dizaine d'années vous le
voyez sur les écoles de fans de vous
pour vous qui êtes en plateau
véritablement il y a dix ans et un
chantier d'envergure qui a débuté comme
en voisin est arrivé sur ce projet en
fait nous le
le souci qu'on avait c'est que les
élèves de nos écoles primaires allait à
la piscine à chevreuse
donc il devait prendre les transports
scolaires pour aller jusqu à chevreuse
donc le coup était quand même très très
important et donc je crois que l'entente
entre les deux villes a permis de régler
ce problème là et maintenant les enfants
de voisins vont pratiquement virée à
pied ou en bus mais sinon les écoles
sont quand même pas trop trop loin donc
pour nous c'est un vrai confort de pour
la ville la ville de voisins qui a
participé à l'époque à hauteur de 26%
c'était en comparaison avec la
population de la ville sur cet équilibre
relax que la réalisation a vu le jour
les autres communes ne souhaitait pas
participer à ce projet à l'époque
à ma connaissance non plus sur ces 2
s'est fait présenter une initiative au
départ montigny le bretonneux et les
seuls qui ont souhaité s'y associer
c'était voisins le bretonneux montigny
et voisins et le site qui fête donc ses
10 en quelques chiffres encore 8 105 m²
de plans d'eau plus de trois cent mille
visiteurs par an vous êtes satisfait des
résultats obtenus sur la fréquentation
aujourd'hui sur le rythme de croisière
de ce complexe
objectivement relativement mena en
sachant qu'on peut quand même un
accueillir un peu plus c'est le c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle on
essaye de le valoriser à travers
l'animation des dix ans et puis
également qu'on essaye de l'actualiser
on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure
avec quelques investissements nombreuses
années dessiné par visiter un jour il
n'y a pas que la natation qui est
possible sur ce site
forcément c'est un complexe aquatique
mai mais au-delà de ça vous avez
développé des activités annexes
dans will
la relaxation déjà et puis tout ce qui
est partie remise en forme
on a regroupé tout ce qui était un petit
peu partout sur sur la ville dans ce
centre aquatique
donc c'est sans oublier les agrès dans
l'eau oui oui oui oui oui sur la lauch à
nous que nous avons testée prochainement
seigneur mais devra certainement ça très
bien pour la rédaction pour un prochain
c'est bien cela va rester au goût du
jour puisque c'est à la mode
on sait qu'il faut savoir qu'on est bien
ici pour plus de 50000 euros quand même
sur ces appareils qui occupent les deux
bassins circulaire qui tuent tant à
l'intérieur c'est bien d'avoir un bel
écrin mais encore faut-il qu'il y ait
quelque chose à l'intérieur on va
continuer à parler des investissements
que vous avez réalisé on va juste se
rendront en coulisses à présent nous
sommes allés voir comment fonctionner ce
centre comment cela se déroulait aux
coulisses il ya du travail vous allez le
voir
valérie auribeau patrick jacques de
dixmude un peu plus de cinquante mille
mètres cubes d'eau par an pour un nouvel
apport de 100 litres d'eau par jour dans
les bassins 600 mètres cubes d'eau pour
le bassin sportif 300 pour le bassin
ludique et 30 mètres cubes d'eau pour le
bassin des toboggans le centre aquatique
du lac de montigny le bretonneux fête
cette semaine ses dix ans d'existence en
grande pompe l'eau des bassins est
rentrer dans un circuit dans un supplice
filtration à passe dans un espèce de
gros réservoirs qu'on peut voir derrière
nous et dans ses réservoirs il y à du
sable et au contact du sable l'eau est
débarrassé de ses impuretés ensuite
avait traité avec du chlore et avait
réinjecté dans le bassin l'eau des
bassins est ici traitée au chlore gazeux
en fonction du nombre de personnes
présentes dans l'eau les pompes analyse
la quantité de chlore actif dans les
bassins et injectent plus ou moins de
clore en fonction des besoins
les agents de la piscine rendent compte
deux fois par jour de la propreté de
l'eau l' agence régionale de la santé
inspectent elle l'état de l'eau une fois
par mois on a
une eau qui est désinfecté c'est à dire
que ne transporte pas de microphones
mems est allé désinfectantes
si une personne vient avec une plaie par
exemple cette clé sera désinfecter par
l'eau de la piscine
les 180 mille mètres cubes de chauffage
au gaz à nu elles permettent une
température de 30 degrés aux abords des
bassins pour une température de 27
degrés dans le bassin sportif et 29 30
degrés pour le bassin ludique près de
300000 personnes fréquentent chaque
année le centre aquatique du lac dont
18% représentée par les groupes
scolaires collèges et lycées de montigny
et voisins le bretonneux et ça fait dix
ans que ça dure dans le reportage il
était question des groupes scolaires
justement est ce que l'équilibré
aujourd'hui entre les groupes scolaires
le grand public est bon vous
souhaiteriez avoir développé un peu plus
justement le côté grand public mais non
je pense que la volonté des deux villes
c'est de continuer à envoyer tout le
maintien de classes primaires du cp
jusqu'au cm2 est-ce qu'on perd de
l'argent sur un tel complexe c'est
justement quand on décide de laisser la
priorité aux écoles puisque c'est le but
tout de même la priorité aux écoles et
au public
bien sûr bon si on parle de chiffres
c'est un déficit avoisinant les 500
mille euros sur parents bien sûr sur un
budget de à peu près un million et demi
d'euros
comment réduire ses déficits parce que
j'imagine que vous regarder à la loupe
les moindres dépenses sur ça peut bien
sûr bien sûr c'est le travail du comité
de suivi dont commun
la ville de voisins et de montigny pour
essayer de réduire au maximum ce déficit
quelles sont les pistes on peut imaginer
à laser sont des choses que du bonheur
du jeu en disant on a quand même
déjà travaillé c'est bien sur les
économies d'énergie les économies d'eau
économies d'énergie surtout on a refait
des normes d'énormes progrès mais bon
c'est un équipement comme ça je vois pas
comment on peut voltalia l'origine qui
aideront le tazer l'investissement l'on
gagne en un déficit sur la piscine
tournesol dans le temps et on savait que
d'avoir également un déficit c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle les
deux villes ont voulu absolument
réserver sa à leur colère et au public
de façon réduire réduire le déficit en
sous-entendus mais surtout donner
satisfaction aux populations des deux
villes on va écouter juste avant ce
qu'en pense le public de ce centre nous
sommes allés réalisé un petit micro
trottoir juste un mot puisqu'on parlait
de l'entretien avec le reportage de de
la rédaction il ya quelques instants les
normes évoluent aussi régulièrement mais
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
travaux à faire qui sont obligatoires et
des choses qui n'étaient pas forcément
budgété planifié prévu qui lui remet
très régulièrement
ça se discutait régulièrement au comité
de suivi et puis à tenerife par les deux
conseils municipaux celui de
voisins-le-bretonneux de montigny chaque
année qu'en pensent les paddocks alors
nous allons les écouter écouter si l'on
fréquente régulièrement ce centre
l'ambiance est agréable on travaille
bien c'est que du bonheur
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est les des
appareils on peut nager
puis là ils ont mille nouveaux appareils
d'un an c'est parfait moi ça me convient
très bien je viens de rambouillet
d'ailleurs il ya une très bonne
ambiance voilà une beaucoup de sympathie
entre les adhérents et c'est très bien
ben ça c'est bien quand même d'avoir
aussi leurs allocations que ça la gym et
mais c'est dommage que tous les jours ça
ou que le midi on ignore quel comme ça
quoi
les animateurs sont très sympa
l'ambiance est chaleureuse on communique
beaucoup en rigole beaucoup et on
travaille beaucoup je viens en dehors
des scolaires mais bon mais je le trouve
très bien très bien conçue très agréable
c'est parfait vos réactions à chacun le
public est satisfait même si on a
entendu justement cette petite peut-être
critique s'est ouvert seulement les sur
l'heure du midi
pour ceux qui ne sont pas scolaire et
bien sûr priorité aux scolaires et puis
public après on peut pas imaginer un
fonctionnement qui permettrait d'allier
à la fois les scolaires et le plat
viande qu'elle soit accueillie semaine
dans la maison du mal déjà à passer tous
les scolaires tous les scolaires parce
que il ya une journée qui réservait pour
la ville de voisins et trois journées
pour la ville de montigny des avec les
rythmes c'est le changement des rythmes
scolaires qui se profile puis ce profil
je pense que ça ne va pas nous
simplifier la tâche
effectivement il y aura des scolaires à
accueillir beaucoup plus souvent
peut-être de l'année prochaine ou
l'année suivante en fonction des
communes vous le savez que ce réforme
des des rythmes scolaires dont nous
avons déjà largement parlé par rapport
au micro trottoir convient d'entendre ça
fait plaisir ça fait plaisir de la
d'investir dans cet équipement c'est
vrai depuis dix ans on fonctionne
toujours autant vous avez évoqué
l'investissement départ ou
vous avez versé 26% là surtout les frais
de l'équipement voisins continuent à
verser tous les ans 26% que ce soit en
fonctionnement ou un investissement donc
quand on voit un retour comme ça des
usagers bas c'est vrai que ça fait but
voilà c'est une récompense ça fait
plaisir c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
centres au tour qui offre aussi
maintenant des choses intéressantes mais
je crois que si on arrive à fidéliser
notre notre public c'est quand même
c'est quand même très positif et puis il
ya eu beaucoup de travaux pour améliorer
et même là encore cette année qui sont
prévues pour améliorer ou de réflexion
du halage en visant forcément vous les
avez un commandant dix ans ce centre
aquatique en aura on leur a grandit
encore plus grand cette fois sa place à
oui il nous reste c'est ça ça avait
l'air d'être une surprise il nous reste
à aménager et tout tout l'espace
extérieur
on a quelques mètres carrés quand même
tout autour sans trop imaginer pourrait
plus grands d'ici une dizaine d'années
pourquoi pas en tout cas faudra déjà
célébré ses 10 premières années on est
il ya plusieurs rendez-vous qui sont
prévues on peut peut-être mentionné
quelques-uns ya une soirée nocturne
notamment le vendredi 22 il y aura des
cours collectifs aussi pour découvrir
les activités proposées comme l'aquagym
ça c'est gratuit avec le prix d'entrée
19 20 21 et concours de déguisement
aussi on peut se déguiser pour aller à
la piscine comme curieux de découvrir ça
oui c'est effectivement ses conseillers
sinon quels sont les rendez vous et ce
qui est un moment fort particulier
auquel il faut surtout pas manquer de se
rendre pour ces festins le lancement ce
lancement officiel de ce soir mais sinon
bon je pense que ça intéresse le but
c'est de faire découvrir l'ensemble du
centre des personnes qui ne le
connaissent pas et leur faire aussi
découvrir tous les efforts tous les
investissements que nous avons fait
dernièrement que ce soit un entretien
que ce soit un équipement il ya un
programme pluriannuel également qui est
prévu pour le renouvellement
de tout le matériel qui commence aussi à
accuser pour tout ce qui est remise en
forme donc pense que le public te rue du
tour et son compte également et on va
vous laisser partir justement puisque
vous devez vous y rendre sur cette
soirée de lancement d'une opération pour
c pour ses 10 ans inauguration non mes
célébrations en tout cas de décès de dix
ans du centre merci donc à tous les deux
rendez vous jusqu'au 28 février au
centre aquatique du lac pour cet
anniversaire à montigny le bretonneux
dans une dizaine de minutes selon le
résumé complet de l'actualité sportive
du week-end mais déjà le résumé de
guyancourt à linas-montlhéry c'est du
football est la rencontre s'est déroulée
ce dimanche les images le soleil faisait
son retour ce week-end sur les pelouses
saint-quentinoise une éclaircie qui n'a
pas empêché guyancourt de sombrer rares
domicile dès le premier quart d'heure de
jeu linas montlhéry ouvre le score sur
ce cafouillage de la défense centrale
pour la suite cette première mi-temps
est une compilation de fautes et
d'action manqué par les rouges et jaunes
et surtout de ce but lui encore toi
refusé pour hors jeu
et en cours encaissera deux autres buts
score final 3 0
avec ce revers les joueurs détiennent
ridet subissent leur seconde défaite
consécutive et n'ont toujours pas
remporté un match en 2013 mais ils
restent leaders de leur poule de
promotion d'honneur avec trois points
d'avancé sur l'entente parisienne